حقيقه تهديد امبابي بالاعتزال لعيون حكيمي
وازمه الفيش وحكيمي تفتح نقاش كيف المفروض
الانديه تتعامل مع اتهام لاعبيها
بالاغتصاب والسلطات الايرانيه تؤكد 90% من
الطالبات بيعانوا من التوتر وما تسمموا
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اخبار تطورات سريعه بنسمعها عن قضيه
الاغتصاب اللي متهم فيها اللاعب المغربي
اشرف حكيمي واحدث هذه التطورات تصريحات
الحكيمه على لسان احد جيرانه القصه يعني
كده علشان اذكركم هي انه في فتاه تعرف
عليها حكيمي عبر انستجرام وتوجهت لي
الشرطه واتهمت حكيمي باغتصابها في منزله
قرب باريس في الخامس والعشرين من فبراير
والبنج قالت للشرطه انها بتبلغ عن الحادثه
بس وما تبغى تقدم شكوى ولكن القضاء
الفرنسي قرر يفتح تحقيق بسبب نوع الحادثه
وشهره حكيمي وبعدها بكم يوم تم رسميا
توجيه تهمه الاغتصاب لحكيمي واستجوبه
البنت حكيمي من اول يوم على لسان محاميته
بينفي الاتهامات وبياكد ثقته في العداله
وبيقول انه متعاون مع السلطات وبيقدم لك
كل اللي بتطلبه وكنا كشفنا في تفاعلكم ان
نقدم للسلطات سجل الرسائل بينه وبين البنت
على انستغرام بينما البنت ما قدمتها
للشرطه لما طلبوها منها وقالت انها مسحت
انستجرامها حكيمي كمان في الاتهامات
لوالدته اللي صرحت وقالت انه ابنها اقسم
لها انه ما عمل شيء مثل هذا
والجديد اليوم هي تصريحات اللي حكيمي
نقلها احد اصدقاء طفولته وجاره في الحي
اللي تربى فيه في ختافي فيه اسبانيا واللي
نقل لبرنامج رياضي اسباني انه حكيمي قال
له نصا ما حدث كان مدبرا تم خداعي وصديق
طفوله حكيمي قال كمان انه اللاعب وعيلته
بيعانوا من اللي جالس بيصير وانه الله
وحده يعلم الحقيقه
هذه الروايه كانت صرحت فيها المحاميه كمان
اللي قالت انه موكلها ضحيه ابتزاز في
معلومات متداوله كمان اليوم عن زوجه حكيمي
الممثله الاسبانيه هبه عبو كل ملتزمه
الصمت من اول ما تفجرت القصه وطلعت انباء
عن انها طالبه الطلاق اصلا من قبل الحادث
باسابيع والناس شافت اونلاين انها ولديها
كانوا في اجازه في دبي وقت ما مفروض انه
صارت الواقعه وطلعت الناس من حسابها صوره
معينه نزلت في نفسي يوم الواقعه وفيها هبه
والولدين متصورين امام برج العرب في دبي
[موسيقى]
وفي قضيه حكيمي في شخص ثاني من اول القصه
الانظار متوجهه له وفي انتظار رده فعله مو
مرته ولوالدته وانما زميله في النادي
باريس سان جيرمان
وصديقه المقرب الفرنسي كيليان مبابي
الاثنين معروفين انه بتجمعهم علاقه شخصيه
قويه جدا وصداقه بتتعدى مجرد الزماله في
المهنه او في النادي والناس جالسه بتستنى
تشوف اي رده فعل من مبابي وفجاه ملت
المنصات تغريده وخبر انه يهدد الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم انه راح يعتزل دوليا
اذا ما ثبتت براءه صديقه حكيمي وهذا الخبر
كان متداول منسوب لمحطه تي في سانك
الفرنسيه الشهيره وبيقول انه هدد
بالاعتزال دوليا في حال وقع ظلم بحق حكيمي
وانه طلب من نادي باريس سان جيرمان
واللاعبين يساندوه في المحنه اللي بيمر
فيها في ناس صدقت وبدات تمدح في مبابي
الصديق الوفي وناس ثانيه تنتقل وتقول مو
منطقي لكن شويه بحث اظهرت الحقيقه وانه
التصريح مفبره كل موضوع ماله اساس من
الصحه وعموما اصلا يعني يهدد الاتحاد
الفرنسي لكره القدم الاتحاد اصلا ما له اي
علاقه بالموضوع اللي صاير واللي منظور
امام القضاء حاليا وعشان نكون قفلنا كل
التطورات في القضيه لازم نقول انه اداره
باريس سان جيرمان اختارت حكيمي علشان
يسافر مع النادي لمواجهه فريق بايرن ميونخ
ضمن دوري ابطال اوروبا
[موسيقى]
طيب في الوقت الراهن في اكثر من لاعب كبار
او لاعب او يعني لاعبين كبار بيواجهوا
اتهامات بالاقتصاد مثلا عندنا البرازيلي
داني الفيش مسجون ووضعه في قضيته او وضعه
صعب صراحه في قضيه نادي كما نتخلى عنه
وفسخ التعاقد مع فورا اول ما طلعت القصه
وفي طبعا اشرف حكيمي اللي ناديه للان في
صف وداعمه ولسه بيتمرن معاهم وضمن
التشكيله والنادي طلع بيان بيدعمه فيه
وبيقول انه معاه حتى تتحقق العداله لكن
حتى قبل البس وحكيمي في اكثر من لاعب سبق
يعني واتهموا ونواديهم تعاملت مع القصص
خلينا نقول بطرق مختلفه على سبيل المثال
وليس الحصر مثلا عندنا الانجليزي
جمد عضويه وراتبه وقت التحقيق معه ومع انه
لاحقا اسقطت التهم عنه لكن مع كدا النادي
للان بيقول انه مستقبله في النادي مو
مضمون المصري امامكم الان على الشاشه عمرو
ورده لمن اتهم وكان في اليونان النادي
استبعدوا واعروا لنادي برتغالي والنادي
البرتغالي بعدها بثلاثه ايام وعلى خلفيه
اتهامات تحرش استبعدوا ورجعوا لنادي
اليوناني المقصود نقوله من كل هذه القصص
انه على مر السنوات والقصص كل مره كنا
بنشوف ردات فعل مختلفه من النوادي على
اتهامات لاعبيها بالاغتصاب او التحرش او
الاعتداء الجنسي والسؤال هنا لاي درجه
الانديه بتتضرر لما نلاعبيها بيتهموا بقصص
مثل هذه حتى ولو ما اثبتت مثلا على
اللعيبه او لم يدانوا لاحقا وسؤال الثاني
هل هناك رده فعل معينه ممكن نقول انها
يعني النموذجيه او التعامل الصحيح لازارات
النوادي مع قصص مثل هذه خاصه وانه عالم
كره القدم تحديدا ونظرا طبعا للشهره
والفلوس والاضواء اللي في صرنا بنسمع عن
حوادث من هذا النوع للحديث اكثر في هذا
الموضوع بينضم الينا من القاهره الاعلامي
والمحلل الرياضي اسر حسين اهلا فيك معانا
ايش رايك الان في تعامل النادي مع اشرف
حكيمي خلينا نبتدي بالنموذج او المثال
اللي عندنا اياه موجود الان
طيب برحب بك طبعا في برنامجك المحترم
جمهورك يمكن الفكره مع اشرف حكيمي هو انه
التوقيت حدوث او توقيت الاتهام انه احنا
بنتكلم على واحد من اهم النجوم العرب مع
طبعا مناصفه مع محمد صلاح ومع حكيم زياش
والنجوم العربي اللي شرفت الكره الاوروبيه
كمان هو دلوقتي بعد ايام او بعد فتره
قصيره من انجاز تحقيق المغرب لرابع العالم
والوصول لنصف النهائي لاول مره كاول فريق
عربي افريقي حق ده تبقى
الاتهام يبقى اتهام حتى يثبت ادانه المتهم
يعني كل اللي حصل انه انه ذهبت السيده دي
وقالت انه للبوليس وقالت ان السبت قبل
الماضي زي ما حضرتك قلت في المقدمه تم انه
كانت في منزله تم عمليه الاغتصاب وبالتالي
صرحت طبعا المحاميه بتاعه اشرف حكيمي انه
ده يبقى اتهام بس وان من خلال توليها
القضيه او الاتهام انه اللي جمع من
المعلومات من البوليس او او الش القضائيه
هناك هي بتعتبر انه حتى الان هي عمليه
ابتزاز واستغلال
موقف النادي حتى الان
لا انا بشوف انه
الموضوع بياخد لازم نقول ان هو بياخد
مراحل انه
تطرحي سؤال النوادي بتتعمل ازاي انه بعد
بعد اللي حصل وكانت نجوم كبار هدف لاكثر
من عمليه من ده او تعرضت لانه كانوا بيتم
اتهامهم بده ان النوادي لازم تكون متاهبه
لحاجه زي كده انه وارد جدا يكون كل قوه
فريق زي الانجليز بيقولوا يعني الباد ابل
او ان لعيب او كانسان يقدم على حاجه زي دي
سواء بالتحرش الجنسي او بالاغتصاب وشفنا
اكثر من حاله فبالتالي النادي لازم يكون
متاهب لان المرحله الاولى زي ما باريس
بيعمل بعتقد زي ما حضرتك قلت اه انا بتفق
معهم لانه اللاعب حتى يثبت عليه شيء بيدمج
فيه السكواد او القائمه اللي رايحه تلاعب
في مباراه مصريه في دوري الابطال والفريق
خسران على الارض في برانس واحد صفر يعني
محتاج انه يعوض الهزيمه عشان يصعد حتى
الان في البدايه بتحمل اللاعب بتاعك الى
ان يثبت عكس ده عندنا نموذج ثاني مهم جدا
نموذج مانشستر يونايتد اللي برده التزم
الصمت في قضيه اللاعب اللي كان متهم متهيا
مباشر بالاقتصاد الى ان صدر تسجيلات على
السوشيال ميديا بتوثق
تسجيلات صوتيه للي حصل اثناء عمليه
الاغتصاب فبالتالي كانت موجه عارمه الغضب
لما نوقفوا راتبه واتخذوا القرارات كانوا
كانهم يعني ما كان اودين رسميا كانوا
كانهم بيرفعوا يده يدهم منه انه ما لهم
دخل وبعدين هم تورطوا لما اسقطت عنه
الاتهامات يعني صار الوضع صعب الاتهامات
اسقطت وهم مو قادرين يرجعوه الان يعني
حضرتك حاجه اللي حاصل دلوقتي انه بالضبط
هي المعضله دي هي انه هم ما بين او بصدد
انه عايزين يرجعوا لعيب لان بالنسبه
لمانشستر يونايتد الموضوع بعتقد هيكون
اقتصادي بحت او الموضوع بتفكر فيه او
المكاسب ده للنادي بس لانه اللاعب عنده 21
سنه لو استرجع اللاعب ثاني او اعاده تعاقد
ما هيوفر حوالي 100 مليون استرليني في
لاعب كم السجل التهديفي بتاعه ممتاز جدا
واحد عناصر الشابه المنتخب انجلترا لكن
اديكي مثال على عنوانه تقرير كان نازل على
صحيفه اتلتيك بتقول انه لو رجع مانشستر
يونايتد جريند دي تبقى هزيمه لكره القدم
عنوان عنيف جدا بيؤكد حاله الغضب اللي
موجوده بانه فريق السيدات في في حتى الان
رافض او بيتكلم على انه مش يعني مش شايف
انه الاصح عوده اللاعب بعد ان ثبت عليه
اسقطت الاتهام صحيح لانه الضحيه تراجعت عن
التسجيلات او تم الضغط عليها لكن هم
عايزين يقولوا انه احنا بنتكلم على لاعب
اي
مده السجن او مده العقوبه لكنه اثبت عليه
انه ممكن يقدم على اغتصاب فبالتالي لا
يمكن ان يدمر تاني داخل حتى اللاعب نفسه
بيفكر في خوض تجربه في الصين ان لم يعد
يونايتد
هو واضح انه جاي عليه عروض كثيره كمان
لصغر سنه يعني كمان في هذا الموضوع بس
خليني انتقل معك بالسريعا عشان الوقت
لنقطه اخرى
في التعامل بين الانديه العربيه والانديه
الاجنبيه يعني طبعا في القصه الشهيره اللي
عمرو ورده الي حتى تحول الموضوع وهو بيلعب
في المنتخب يعني باسم بلده واستمر هناك
بعتقد الضرر اللي حصل
وسؤال مهم جدا سؤال ذكي جدا اللي حصل في
قضيه عمرو ورده في 2019 وكانت مصر الدوله
منظمه لكاس امم افريقيا وظهر ما ظهر من
اللاعب التهم بالتحرش او من خلال الرسائل
لاحد احد العرضات الازياء المصريين انه
الدعم اللي حصل من اللعيبه كان دعم خاطئ
جدا لانه كان تاكد ساعتها انه اللاعب اقدم
على ده وكان نجوم فريق كبار في منتخب مصر
نزلوا حتى وصل الدعم الى دعم يعني او دعم
غير من غير حتى الرجوع
او حتى يستنوا انه تثبت براءته ورفعوا
بالظبط غير مشروط تماما ورفعوا تيشرت
بتاعه كانه يعني احد ابطال الفريق
فبالتالي كان خطا كبير جدا لانه بعد ده
وبعد موجه عارمه من غضب الجمهور المصري
اضطر الاتحاد المصري ساعتها براس هاني ابو
رضا انه استبعد اللاعب خالص منتخب الوطني
ومن اي انه ينضم تاني لاحد المنتخبات
الوطنيه حتى النادي بتاعه فسخ التعاقد معه
بيلعب في الدوري القبرصي فبالتالي اعتقد
التعامل كان سيء جدا لانه كان بيمثل مصر
ساعتها
وما كانش
الترويج الجيد لانه لاعب لما يحصل كده حتى
محمد صلاح نجمنا وفخر العرب يعني انا كنت
في انجلترا في الوقت ده وفي لندن هوجن
بشكل كبير انه ازاي قبلت انك تكون معاه في
نفس الفريق او توافق انه ينضم بعدها والى
اليوم هذه النقطه بتلاحق وكل ما احد بده
يهاجمه يذكره او يسترجعوا له موقفه في
قضيه عمرو ورده على العموم احنا بنشكرك
على هذه المداخله كان معنا من القاهره
الاعلامي والمحلل الرياضي اسر حسين شكرا
لك
اهلا من جديد عارفين لما الواحد يجيله
كثير تعليقات على موضوع معين فيقرر انه
يسبقهم ويعلق هو على نفسه قبل ما اي احد
ثاني كذا يعلق يعني بالضبط هذا اللي عمله
الرئيس الامريكي
وتعليقاتهم المستمره على صحته وقوى
العقليه وقرر هو ينكت على الموضوع
تصريح بايدن في المؤتمر السنوي للرابطه
الدوليه لرجال الاطفاء في واشنطن نتكلم
معاهم وشكرهم على انقاذ حياته في عام 1988
وكشف عن معلومات طبيه اول مره الناس
بتسمعها مثل اصابته بتمدد الاوعيه الدمويه
في الدماغ عام 88 واجراء عمليه جراحيه
لمعالجه التمدد وهناك نكت على الموضوع
وقال انه في العمليه فتحوا راسي كذا مره
علشان يشوفوا لو عندي مخ طبعا ما بيخفى
على احد الكلام عن صحه بايدن من اول يوم
تولى الرئاسه فهو اكبر الرؤساء سنا والان
مع اعلان ترشحوا لولايه ثانيه الكلام زاد
اكثر واكثر خاصه من معارضي اللي بيلعبوا
كثير على ورقه انه صحته مو تمام وبصراحه
حتى الان سجل بايدن كمان مو مساعدهم كثير
فمن كم يوم طبيب بايدن النشر مذكره لوسائل
الاعلام قال فيها انه في ورم سرطان يتشخص
في الرئيس في صدره وتم ازالته في 16
فبراير وحاول يطمن الناس انه ورم صغير ومو
من النوع اللي بينتشر بس يعني الناس مسكت
في الموضوع طبعا مع انه اطباء البيت
الابيض طلعوا تقرير من اسابيع عن قديش صحه
الرئيس عظيمه وانه لائق صحيا غير موضوع
السرطان هذا في كمان تصريحات الرئيس وزلات
لسانه المتكرره واللي مخوفه معارضي وفي
كمان تعثروا وسقوط واكثر من مره وخصوصا
على سلالم الطائره والعلمكم امس تعثر
عليها ثاني وهو ماشي يركب الطياره من
الباما
[موسيقى]
مستمرين معاكم كمان مشاهدينا في متابعه
تطورات حالات التسمم اللي بتصيب الطيبات
الايرانيات في المدارس والجامعات واليوم
بعد يوم بنسمع زياده فيها الطالبات صاروا
الاف والمدارس والجامعات صاروا بالمئات
واللي بيصير انه الطالبات في الحرم
المدرسي او الجامعي بيستنشقوا غاز ما حد
لسه عارف ايش هو ولا من فين مصدره وبتظهر
عليهم اعراض تسمم وبيتنقلوا للمستشفيات
وبعد تجاهل وانكار لفتره شفنا امس
القيادات الايرانيه بتعترف بالازمه وبتفتح
تحقيق وقال يعني بتقول لازم نعاقب
المتورطين بس في نفس الوقت شايفينها
مؤامره ضد البلد
[تصفيق]
السلطات لا قالت مين هدول اللي اعتقلتهم
ولا ايش علاقتهم في الموضوع ولا اي تفاصيل
لكن الداخليه كانت اصدرت بيان كمان قالت
فيه انه تحقيقاتها للان توصلت لانه في 250
فصل في انحاء البلاد تعرضوا للهجمات من
الطالبات التي تاثروا عددهم محدود مدري
يعني كانوا يبغوا العدد كم يعني يكون
علشان يحسبوها ويحسبوها كارثه يعني على
العموم البيان او بيان الداخليه قال كمان
انه فحصوا عينات من المتضررات وتبين انه
ما في مواد سامه او خطيره وانه اقل من 5%
طلعت عليهم اصلا اعراض اما 9% من الطالبات
اللي نقلوا او 90% عفوا من الطالبات اللي
نقلوا للمستشفيات ما كانوا من اللي تسمموا
لا كانوا من الطالبات اللي اثرت عليهم
الحادثه نفسيا يعني شافت زميلتها او
رفيقتها متسممه فتاثرت وخافت على نفسها
طيب لسه ما خلصت النتائج طولوا بالكم معي
نتابع البيع لانه البيان وقال انه اللي
صار عمل اجرامي متعمد ومستمرين في البحث
في هذا المجال اما النتيجه اللي انا ما
اعرف ايش قصدهم فيها فقالوا فيها انه بعض
الحالات اللي تسببت في التهابات ناتجه عن
اعمال المغامره وما شرحوا ولا وضحوا ايش
يعني اعمال المغامره طيب اذا كان بيان
وزاره الداخليه وزاره الصحه هي كمان كان
لها تصريحات انه ترى 10% بس من الطالبات
عانوا اعراض حقيقيه والباقيين كله توتر
وقلق وقالوا انه المواد المستخدمه في
الهجمات هي مواد متاحه وعلى فكره السلطات
الايرانيه لها كم يوم بتسمي المواد هذه
اللي تعرضت لها الطالبات منشطات لغسان ولا
مواد خطيره ولا شيء لا لا هذه منشطات بحسب
كلامهم طيب عموما الاحتجاجات مكمله في
الشوارع والناس بتطالب تفهم ايش اللي جالس
بيصير
[موسيقى]
هات البيت الابيض تدخل امس وطلعت
السكرتيره الاعلاميه كريم جون بيير وقالت
انه راح يكون في تفويض للبعث الدوليه
المستقله لتقصي الحقائق في ايران للتحقق
في الموضوع
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
انا اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من تفاعلكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]